si il y a une chose que j'ai toujours
cru c'est le fameux slogan de Monsieur
Barack Obama yes week en
2011 à mes saisons j'obtiens mon diplôme
de baccalauréat série D au lycée privé
qui balade de Moussa modo
cette année fut déterminé pour moi
mon père rêvait d'un jeune chirurgien
mais moi n'ayant aucun affinité dans le
domaine de la santé et têtu comme je
suis j'ai suivi ma passion avec
conviction
démon plus jeune âge je voyais très
facilement qu'une machine d'une taille
considérable pouvait se déplacer dans
les airs d'un point à un autre j'ai
commencé à m'y intéresser via le
des avions papier des cerfs-volants etc
ce fut le commencement de ma passion au
2L très peu d'informations me
parvenaient compte aux possibilités
d'orientation je savais pas par où
commencer vers qui me diriger comment
postuler donc j'ai décidé d'aller à
Madagascar là-bas je choisis une
formation technique et une formation en
langue anglaise une langue qui est
indispensable dans le domaine
aéronautique
quelques mois passés à Madagascar
j'apprends que la Russie facilitait ses
accès universitaires aux étudiants
africains j'ai donc pas hésité j'ai
postulé et boum j'ai été admis dans
l'une des universités les plus
prestigieuses dans l'une des universités
aéronautiques de Moscou le MI le Moscow
aviation institut université nationale
d'état de recherche je m'envole pour
Moscou bien évidemment mon intégration
dans ce nouveau système universitaire où
la langue est totalement différente des
langues que je connaissais le français
le Comorien l'anglais ou les conditions
climatiques étaient à l'opposé du
confort nous qui sommes habitués du
climat des pays tropical cette
intégration dans ce nouveau système n'a
pas été facile
mais comme le dicton le dit aide-toi et
le ciel t'aidera
la Russie est un pays où très peu de
Comoriens s'y intéresse mais mon but
majeur était pour obtenir des
connaissances et en plus la Russie fait
partie des pays qui ont marqué
l'histoire dans le domaine aéronautique
c'est parmi les pays qui ont
même conçu un avion de ligne
supersonnique cela a été une très grande
motivation pour je suis quelqu'un qui
aime bien se démarquer
j'aime bien faire la différence donc je
me suis dit que faire la même chose
pourraient être un blocage pour le
développement de notre pays donc j'ai
choisi de suivre ma passion avec
conviction dont j'estime être un besoin
du pays en parlant de moi
je suis quelqu'un de je suis quelqu'un
de taille court donc je vous laisse
imaginer mon arrivée à Moscou quand je
vois que tout le monde est grand de
taille petite anecdote
une fois on a eu des jeux sportifs au
sein de l'université
adepte du football j'ai donc participé
et j'ai pu me démarquer via ma vitesse
et ma rapidité le lendemain en cours un
des profs a commencé à commenter les
événements et a fait sortir une carte de
vos noms et il m'a interpellé mais Ben
où est-ce que tu as pu t'entraîner pour
ta vitesse alors que ton pays est un
point minuscule dans le kart
bien évidemment les les autres étudiants
ont commencé à rigoler et ont commencé à
s'y intéresser des Comores
après quelques années d'apprentissage
dans une année consacrée
à l'apprentissage de la langue je me
suis vu octroyer le titre d'ingénieur en
aéronautique Oura diplôme en poche
toujours
je rentre au pays je rentre aux
commandes pour objectif de participer
activement
au domaine aéronautique de mon pays
j'intègre alors là en tant que stagiaire
l'aviation civile comorienne Lana cm
dans le bureau de navigabilité après
quelques mois passés dans cette
institution je Decis je décide alors là
de rejoindre une équipe jeune et
dynamique au sein de la Direction
Technique d'Inter Hilaire
compagnie aérienne comorienne après
quelques années passées dans cette
institution
je suis actuellement responsable au
suivi de navigabilité des avions de
cette compagnie je suis aussi membre de
l'association Jeunes el comorient qui a
pour but de promouvoir les métiers de
l'aéronautique aux Comores
si on me reposait la question aux jeunes
saison et Bachelet que j'étais pourquoi
la Russie
pourquoi l'aéronautique je ne répondrai
pas parce que je voulais savoir comment
l'avion vole non je reprendrai parce que
je voulais vivre de ma passion je
voulais aussi connaître les opportunités
et les atouts de mon métier dans mon
pays et aussi le plus important ne pas
se donner soi-même des limites et encore
moins celles imposées par les autres
j'espère être un déclic aux jeunesse
comoriennes et que vous aussi vous
puissiez vivre de votre passion et
prendre votre envol merci